in Spain the number of people who have
died with the corona virus has risen
again the latest numbers from Spain show
that the number of confirmed cases of
the virus is up by over 7,000 bringing
the total to one hundred and seventeen
thousand seven hundred and ten there's
also been 932 new deaths reported which
brings a total number of people who have
lost their lives took over 19 in Spain
to nearly 11,000 well we can speak to
our diplomatic editor domine work horn
who joins us now and looking at that
picture in Spain obviously everyday
people are trying to analyze the course
of the disease what do you make of it
yeah there I don't know and I think you
don't have to caution people against
drawing any conclusions
from sort of day by day changes but if
you look at what's happened in
explaining the figures eyes who say nine
hundred and thirty two deaths taking it
up to ten thousand nine hundred and
thirty five small mercies obviously
we're clutching out here but that is
less than yesterday which is nine
hundred and fifty or the day before the
last 24 hours
so that is the first fall in the numbers
of people dying on a daily basis in
Spain since March the 26th the other I
think consolation in Spain is that
number of new infections seems to be
stabilizing so there were seven thousand
registered new cases of kovat 19
infections and that seems to be now
plateauing in Spain that's also happened
in Italy where that number of new
infections seems to be falling off and
that's been happening for a few days now
which i think is giving encouragement to
all those governments across europe and
america of course and elsewhere who are
saying social distancing is working
italy's being locked down more than any
or longer than any other country and the
italians will be saying that does seem
to be working and if you look at the
number of new infections it is falling
off in italy that will only continue the
government's doctors scientists are
saying if that social distance e
distancing remains in place so 760
deaths in italy yesterday
compared to 471 in France so 53,000
people have died from this virus since
the outbreak began and still going up by
almost a thousand a day in Spain so
looking at these statistics there's some
encouragement that policies seem to be
beginning to work but still horrendous
numbers of people dying and a warning
also I think we have to bear in mind
from European you know universities nine
leading European universities have
warned that the the stocks they need the
medical supplies they need for intensive
care application could run out within in
two weeks so it's absolutely essential
that these policies remain in place
doctors and scientists are saying to
keep that a level of new infection down
to get the number of people intensive
care down and also therefore the number
of people dying the hope is will begin
to fall off as well following what we're
beginning to see in some countries in
terms of new infections dominant you
often cover diplomacy international
contacts I mean what level of contact is
going on constructively between national
governments or is it just a question now
of every country for itself I think that
was the case at the beginning at him I
think we got the case very much the
sense at the beginning very much that
governments were in in a state of shock
as much as populations were really
scrambling to keep up what was happening
the pace of events and although they
were staying in touch some countries
with each other it was very much the
focus on what was happening domestically
we did see this attempt by the g20 that
the rotating presidency of which is held
by Saudi Arabia they're kind of virtual
teleconference last week that was
convened by the Saudis that was
criticized because it was seen as
financially not doing enough and it was
seen as rather too many platitudes not
enough action I think the critics the
criticism will still be the government
so far to focus on what's happening in
their own countries we're actually what
is needed to deal with this is
International Solidarity cooperation to
stave off the economic effects of what
is happening to help that the least
rich countries who are really struggling
with this even more than Western nations
but also to pull that expertise because
this is a obviously a virus we've only
that's
existed and humans are very known about
have been affected by for a few months
so every bit of new information it's
essentially is pulled and shared and the
effort is to try and pull doing increase
that enterprise to make countries share
their medical information and experience
and I think people are saying still
there's not enough of that hang and it's
not helped I think by the fact that we
have America blaming China and another
night nations blaming China more of a
war of words going on rather than the
kind of international solidarity and
cooperation that is required to deal
with this unprecedented challenge